i
[Music]
am an artist
and i know
cheryl lee ralph gets the emmy's crowd
on their feet right now i'm thrived you
are thriving
[Applause]
the hollywood vet bringing some broadway
magic to tv's biggest night breaking out
in song and tears while accepting the
award for best supporting actress in a
comedy series for her role as barbara
howard on abc's abbott elementary and
the emmy goes to
cheryl lee rowley
the actress seemingly in shock over her
history-making win her first emmy after
a 30-plus year career and when she hits
the stage
[Music]
species
but i sing no
victim song
she belts out a powerful message i
am a woman i
am an artist
and i know
[Applause]
[Music]
it's no surprise the moment led to a
standing ovation cheryl going on to
thank abbott elementary creator quinta
brunson also in tears for being in her
corner and helping get her to this point
to anyone
who has ever
ever had a dream
and thought your dream
wasn't
wouldn't
couldn't come true
i am here to tell you that this is what
believing looks like
this is what striving looks like and
don't you ever
ever give up on you but there is
something to be said you don't do it for
the accolades you don't do it for the
added girls but there is something to be
said for getting those flowers and
feeling it in the morning i almost
almost tackled her on the red carpet i
literally
but there has to be how does that feel
your fill your heart the number of young
actresses
that sent me flowers
literally
and figuratively that wrote me notes and
said thank you miss rel
i know what you went through and i
appreciate your journey because i'm
sitting high up here because you oh my
god those moments just those that's what
hit me really that just gave me chills
because people may not know how many
young women you mentor how many people
you mentor in this business and what you
mean to them and how much you take your
time to stop and talk to these young
ladies about the pitfalls and how to
negotiate contracts and other things
absolutely it's very important you know
i take my service seriously you know
even you know being vice president of
the la local of sag i take all of that
seriously i want people to get involved
in our industry don't just think it's
all about shining in front of the camera
there's so much work and so many details
that take place behind the camera that
truly affect how it is you survive or
thrive in this industry right now i'm
thrived you are thriving
[Music]